so yeah like i fully do please do that
uh because i was gonna do a master's but
i ended up being a bachelor's because i
just
hated uh engineering by the end of it i
got a 2-1 at the end so i was like oh
i'll take it it's good enough yeah yeah
do you have that
in us what the like the rating system i
mean i'm not from the us i'm sorry
[ __ ]
australia is there like different levels
of degree
like yeah like bachelors monsters no so
and the bachelor is like the past right
like the first
like oh first two one two two i don't
know
the second or third i probably got the
lowest
i was like give me the paper i'm [ __ ]
out i gotta go to [ __ ] first baby
oh my god dude you should you would i
wish god was in my
dissertation presentation he would have
[ __ ] cackled this way
so i'll go on a tangent real quick so my
dissertation
was [ __ ] awful a dissertation by the
way is like your final page
yeah yeah yeah it's like 30 pages long
and in my one in engineering we have to
like actually either prove something
like that's been proved before or like
make a device or something so i decided
i'm gonna make uh so we were given a
topic
and my topic my topic was a wave energy
device
now i loved renewable energies and i
loved uh doing that and luckily we had
like one of the
best guys in the uk was the guy who was
my tutor
so i was like yeah dude i can make a
wave energy device
um wave energy devices have never been
proven to like work very well
in concept they work but they don't work
in large scales right right right
um normally it's below the waves
yeah like the flow in the bottom they
use so i was like
but i can do it i can make a device that
will work
i had like no experiencing workshopping
or like making things
yeah so i don't know why i thought this
would go well so i
did this whole paper i wrote this
everything about it about this concept
then i had to build the concept
and it was the biggest piece of [ __ ]
i've ever built in my life
so i deadass made this like pathetic
little wooden thing
with some copper coils strapped to it
and like a bobbing thing
i got like a toilet float and i turned
up to this thing like a kid
like a six-year-old kid was at the
science fair right
at the science fair like it was
literally science fair quality but even
worse than that
and i turn up and i'm like so here i go
through 10 minutes of all this very
detailed
scientific like calculations yeah the
proving and i
[ __ ] i pull out this piece of [ __ ]
cardboard thing like wooden plywood and
i'm like
so you just pull this up and down with
the waves
and it'll make electricity and then i it
i had an led attached one singular led
and he's like it's not powering it and
i'm like you have to go really fast
and so i start doing like [ __ ] this
with the [ __ ] like jacking it off
basically
and he's like so do you know any waves
that go that fast and i was like
no there are no waves that go that fast
i love that's like the most
university professor kind of question
it's it's like the god he like they will
ask you questions where they know the
answer yeah
they just want to see you like [ __ ]
your way through this
so yeah he he has two two people my
tutor
and he was [ __ ] giggling the whole
time when i pulled it out yeah and the
the auditor kind of person who had never
seen before
and i had a dead ass like look her in
the eye be like this is very scientific
very accurate it will work i promise it
was so embarrassing
and everyone before me was in a full
suit and i just turned up in a t-shirt
yeah we had to dress nice
and so it was just [ __ ] painful and
then he kept asking me questions like
can you hook it up to a battery and i'm
like
i don't have any duracells lying around
maybe you do i don't really like them
what you did is that you just made a
device to light an led
i didn't even do that and so yeah i made
it i basically made
a very basic electromagnetic
thing what it sounded like just like you
put the magnet in the coil and it makes
it yeah so
the idea was that it bobs up with the
wave
fleming's left-hand ruler it's like some
[ __ ] people are doing in like the 1600s
right
it's like a science experiment the
problem is that there's too many
variables
in waves yeah you would need like
hundreds of the like little wave devices
but how the [ __ ] are you gonna have that
on top of the waves
this shit's gonna break all the time
basically it doesn't work i [ __ ] up
and i embarrassed myself